All right. Welcome to today's Zoom call. We got a bunch of questions that came in a few reminders to begin with.
I always go to our blog.
That will help answer some of your questions maybe earlier than going waiting for a Zoom call.
And on our website, this little feature, if you go to anywhere, any page on our website, this little thing right here.
A little spyglass feature gives you the ability to search for anything. We have a really good search on our site that you can search for your question.
We probably have written a blog about it or something information about your question.
If not, that's what you're the Zoom calls are for.
Secondly, if you have any issues with leading religious exemptions for vaccine policies that maybe your work is looking for or friends or family member that needs a protocol to help detox from a vaccine or exposure to those that are vaccinated.
We ask that you go to our sister site, my hope for lime.com. And on the blog, you'll see blog posts that detail information on this.
Very, very, very stealthfully. So my hope for lime is our sister site. Go and look.
Let's get to your questions. Number one, has anyone with pancreatic cancer stage for done ozone therapy and what success have the hand for that ozone therapy is a beneficial therapy for a number of things.
So ozone can be done rectally rectil in salvation of ozone. It's where you use an ozone machine to fill up certain content of of
a bag. And then you just like a coffee and you put the tube up your bottom and you empty the contents of the bag of ozone, which is a gas, all three into your rectum and you absorb some of that affects you in different ways.
There's ozone that can be done via the blood. So an IV center, they use ozone that osulates your blood. There can be benefits to that as well.
Do I recommend ozone therapy for cancer?
No, I don't. Different practitioners have different thoughts about that.
But you personally, I don't like ozone for cancer. So ozone is O3. It's an unstable molecule and the one oxygen will break off and leave a whole negative molecule at a molecule of O2.
That's a whole idea. That's a benefit of ozone. So an unstable molecule will break off that other oxygen. And the benefit is when you try to deal with biotoxins, like mold, for instance, that's why I'm a big fan of the ozone generators that are the air purification generators.
If you're putting a small about ozone out into the room, you can smell it through those ozone generators and we have two of them in our clinic.
And the O3 goes out of the room and it's fairly unstable. It tends to donate that oxygen to a living organism, like a mold or bacteria or virus, and it will then make that less stable and kill that bacteria or virus or mold.
I think ozone therapy shines in human use using an intervenously getting it into your body is if you're dealing with chronic line, chronic mold, chronic bacterial infection, something like that.
And I'm not to say that cancer patients don't deal with that too. So if you're a cancer patient that has a major problem in that area, that's where ozone might be something to look into.
However, ozone is giving it off that oxygen molecule that is a negative ion. So it's an ion.
It is by definition a reactive oxygen species. It is an oxygen, it's not oxygen 80 like oh, it's giving us more oxygen.
It's actually giving us reactive oxygen species as well. So that can be cell damaging. So with those air purifier units, you're breathing that ozone in. Is it bad for you? No, in that concentration, it's not.
You can't hurt yourself with those air purifier units unless you turned off the setting where it senses too much ozone and you locked yourself in a closet with it, you breathed in, you could damage your lungs.
But with the setting that you could run at the highest setting, you still can't damage your lungs, you're not getting enough ozone. But if you're putting ozone in your blood or even rectiline, it's so patient of ozone, you are creating reactive oxygen species, which to me, that's what you're all the nutrition you're taking, all the things you're doing with your life as you're trying to decrease reactive oxygen and nitrogen species to help help heal cancer.
Those are the things that can cause cancer. So I'm not a big fan of ozone with cancer. We could talk for a while.
Somebody chatted in, how do we get in touch with someone to adjust my protocol? Please just call the office. If you, if you send an email and you don't hear back from us within a couple of days of the summer weekend, you need to call the office.
Again, we literally get 200 emails a day. So it could have gotten buried. It may have not ever come to us. We have people that say they sent us an email and actually sent it to CO at an ORS clinic.com. Well, we never received it. So make sure you call it your, your liaison call the clinic asked to talk to your liaison.
You can work through that. You could also email your liaison.
Okay. Next question. What is the maintenance protocol for a fed mend is all that's the Joe Tippen's been mend is all protocol. We have blog posts on that and we have it on the store.
Somebody's PSA is 0.07. My coworker's PSA was 20 point for a junus told to call hospice. He started on the fed mend starter pack in September.
And now it's down to 0.07. It's fantastic news. Great to hear that.
Typically, the maintenance dosage is to your comfort level. Now, I can't give you any specifics. This person is not our patient. So when, when, when you guys send in questions, be aware that there's just legalities. I can't answer questions of somebody who isn't our patient inside agreements and things like that.
But in general, any maintenance doses of any supplement or treatment protocol, you just cut it in, in half or that maybe half again.
You still want to stay on some degree of treatment to a point.
If you're out a couple of years and you're doing fantastic, maybe you wouldn't take any for mend is all, maybe you would just pulse it. Maybe you take it for a month and be off for a month, something like that every other month or every other week.
That's called pulsing. There's some benefit to that too.
Next question is it okay to do the right for iron pro wave while eating a meal.
And follow up is it okay to do it while talking on the cell phone. The answer to both of those is yes, you can do that while eating talking on the cell phone.
We just don't recommend doing the iron pro wave while you're, while you're dancing, don't do the iron pro wave while you're dancing.
I tried it.
Next question. If my cancer is slow growing, will it also be slow to die?
The answer to that is no, not necessarily. There's no correlation to slow growing cancer, slow dying cancer.
Everything is going to happen in its own pace. So there's no way to correlate that.
But anything is possible. There's just no way to correlate the equality of that.
Considerate care oncology's programs of nobody knows.
So care oncology's program is a program to use prescription medication to help block metabolic pathways.
We don't use that because we don't write scripts. So we have a number of patients, a couple handful of patients that are doing some sort of care oncology's program.
Some of the drugs make sense to me because there's very few side effects of that drug.
But some of the drugs make less sense to me, unless you're in dire straits because there's a lot of negative side effects to that drug.
So it depends on what drug they're using.
And follow up to this question, my doctor says he doesn't think I'll benefit from a couple of the four drugs. What do you think? Well, there's no way that we could tell us we were testing you with those drugs. And then we have to be careful testing the drugs just because of legal stances.
Have we seen success with those drugs with any breast cancer patients?
Often times I can't give you an answer that because I don't honestly remember.
We have nobody doing nobody that started this.
Working with us and started care oncology in and there, they had this spike in success.
I'd say it didn't work, but it just haven't. I have nothing that I can recall.
A few months ago, during a zoom call, we briefly talked about the sulfagio frequencies, and you would encourage us to look into that.
Pretty much everything I see is related to sound frequencies. Yes, that's true, because those are in the lower range hurts.
And you can play those with sound manufacturers. The details on the sulfagio frequencies has to do with healing frequencies using, I think the sound of bowls where they rub their hand around a bowl.
But any frequency you can still use with light. So the rife machines use sulfagio in a program when I program, so I program the sulfagio frequencies into the rife.
And it's in many of your programs already and you just don't know it.
I know a part of my confuse probably stems from not understanding this light frequency and sound frequencies. And there's benefit feature for both.
Some things better what frequency is you can't get it with sound because it's outside of the sound spectrum.
But the sulfagio are all lower hurts frequencies that you can't get in the sound spectrum. There can be benefit to using both.
So I think you could actually probably on a YouTube channel find the suffrage frequency sound wise and play them on a good speaker system that they can be beneficial.
How many weeks after completion of chemo.
Should I continue pmf therapy. So, um, the answer is we have people that are not good pmf at all. So, and we have people that have a home pmf that are using it every day.
So, um, it's really up to you pmf therapy is really meant to add charge to your cell membranes. That's really how it benefits. Now, it has been shown to help decrease pain.
Does so by stimulating a certain pathway that inhibits that the pain pathway at the court, but to get to neurological.
But it does so by adding charge to those neurons. So you're adding charge to cells that have low charge. That's the real benefit of pmf therapy.
Pmf therapy doesn't kill cancer cells doesn't heal, but it helps stimulate cells and the health of cells. So the longer you could do and the more you could do pmf therapy within reason and say daily.
It's great.
Because there's no downsides to it. So, um, to answer this question as long as you can do it or fits into your schedule or fits into your budget to continue to do pmf therapy. So I assume you're going to a clinic for this.
So pmf therapy just has so many benefits. Are there certain things like RSO, which is Rick Simpson oil, which for those who don't know is very, very concentrated TSH of marijuana.
So are there certain things like RSO detox supplements or other supplements that I should refrain from while doing chemo and radiation. I know I need to not use colloidal silver. So, um, there's some things you want to stay away from with radiation.
So, um, blue, blue, green algae, colloidal silver.
Those are really the most common things that you stay away from if you're doing radiation with chemotherapy. That's a different story. So, chemotherapy is a strong poison oxidizing agent.
That's how it works. You're oxidizing cells. So, if you drank a poison, you would die, if you had the lethal dose of the poison because of the oxidizing of your cells destroys your cells and it causes cell lysis.
You die with rate with chemotherapy. It's the same thing, but to give you a control dose so it doesn't kill you.
Hopefully, you're the cancer because it's highly metabolic, more metabolic than a healthy cell. It's going to uptake the the chemotherapy faster than a healthy cell and we're going to kill the cancer cell through that oxidizing agent.
You don't want to take antioxidants while you're doing chemo because you're kind of defeating the purpose. You're, you're negating a portion of the chemo by using an antioxidant while you're taking an oxidant via chemo.
So, but really, chemo does its work on the cancer within the first 48 hours and then you want to jump on some antioxidants to help help counteract what the chemo would be doing to your body.
So, our key about therapy protocol is on our website, a blog post or you could ask if you're in the A's on for it. We recommend that you go off any strongly antioxidant, cell phylopeic acid, anything that's going to strongly stimulate glutathione production, maybe stay off a curcumin vitamin C.
While you're for that first 48 hours of chemo and then go back on those things because you don't want to, you don't want to negate the effects of the chemo.
I also recommend if you're on, you know, some detox support for your liver, it might be good to hold off on that because you don't want the chemo to detox too quick either.
So, we recommend you go off of things like liver and deer, some milk thistle, some products for like pond water, you might want to back off on that.
Now, there's other people that have a different theory about this to just understand that's the medical theory. And so I'm not opposed to medical theory. And that's what we stand by.
But there's other practitioners that say below you need to use antioxidants and to protect your healthy cells during chemo. So there's some individuals that will completely go 180 degrees against what the oncologist says.
And they'll double up on the antioxidants during chemo because they want to protect your healthy cells. Well, to me, to me that's countered to a little bit because if you're choosing to do chemo to kill the cancer.
But you want it to work. You don't want to negate any of the possible benefits of the chemo. So we recommend that you go off your account since 48 hours and then go back on it.
Let's hop in my coffee enemas to once a day most days and finally that I don't have a little viable that independent of those animals almost like I'm trading my body to eliminate unless I got an animal.
There's truths of that. So if you're doing a daily coffee enemas. Yes, you are trading your body to rely on those enemas for a moment.
And that's a negative. But the positive is you're doing a coffee enemas to stimulate parasympathetic to stimulate detoxification to stimulate immune system function. Remember, your parasympathetic nervous system controls all your immune system function.
All your detoxification, all your rest and relaxation into anxiety, calming your sympathetics, calming your heart, opening up your blood vessels, opening up your
brain for decrease inflammation has so many positive benefits. If you go off the coffee enemas, yeah, might take you a week to really get your balls back and have it.
You can certainly take magnesium and Cape Aloe and set up and other things to get you back into the habit. So there's too many benefits of a coffee enemas to worry about.
Oh, my gosh, I'm dependent upon this. What most patients do is they have those other products, they're listed in your constipation, oh, how sheet that let's say I'm going to go on vacation, not going to go coffee enemas this weekend.
And I know I get a little constipated if I don't do that. So you're going to take vitamin C and magnesium every night.
And a dose that will really help you have a bubble with the next day or Cape Aloe or something like that.
So there's too many positives for the coffee enemas.
I changed breast surgeons and during our discussion, she stated her preference for an MRI to assess breast health. She prefers it because it gives a dynamic picture of what's happening with breast tissue.
In contrast with the static images produced by ultrasound in mammogram.
Find that kind of a funny comment because MRI is still a static picture.
And certainly if you want something that is more dynamic, you'd have to set here to argue with me that ultrasound, one of those three would be the most dynamic because you're moving the head around you can actually see three dimensionally around the ultrasound.
But I asked why this is important since we're looking at tumor. She stated that breast cancer is more than just tumors, which is true. You got inflammation around it and such.
She said the images of the uptake of the die by the breast tissue and it's movement through the breast is important information. Sure, that is good. So I'm all in favor of MRI CT scan, PET scan.
The negative is that they are invasive. So you're using a die, which is gadolinium in MRI.
gadolinium is a heavy metal and some people have a sensitivity to it. And the more you do MRIs, the more chance that you're going to develop a sensitivity and have issues with the gadolinium itself.
So there's just it's just more invasive. So again, you do you I'm not against invasive tests, but you do an invasive test if it's going to change the way you treat the patient.
And you choose to do an invasive test as a patient if you're going to and willing to change the way you treat yourself, you allow somebody to treat you.
So if you're like, oh, I'm this, this tumor is getting larger and more concerned than maybe it's time to do an MRI because maybe you're going to change your treatment program. Maybe you're going to add some chemo, maybe you're going to tweak some other things.
If things are going well, the ultrasound, showing the tumor, staying the same size or hardly growing at all, then why do you and you're not going to change the way you treat it, then why do it invasive test, just to satisfy curiosity of, you know, some doctor.
You don't do that, you don't do something to please somebody else, you do something because it's the right thing for you to do.
And this is where you have to take charge of your health and make that decision or not be pressured to do something that is not what you want to do.
Certainly, if it is what you want to do, go ahead and do that.
It's going to change the way you treat it, then go ahead and do that.
Well, how many invasive tests do you do because they're second is to it.
Okay, with that, we'll open up for questions. If you want to chat in your questions, if you have any, if you want to speak in any questions, you have to unmute yourself.
Hello.
Hi, this is for Ryan Grasher.
You had talked about fenben dissolve.
Is there any negatives to taking that while taking chemo and radiation?
I can't legally say that about taking it while taking chemo and radiation from just a medical legal standpoint, but no, there is there is you could do Google scholar search yourself.
And there are no studies on that at all.
Showing any positive or negative.
So all the positive information about fenben is actually I think there are some studies showing positive information about I remember to the end that is on for cancer treatment.
But there are no negative ones.
So are there anecdotal clinical data negatives for taking fenben is so the most negative comments that you get.
And the negative comments that you get for taking fenben is maybe a mild stomachache if you had some food when you take it.
What is sex people are mild stomachache for taking vitamin C to so it hasn't stopped anybody from taking it.
So there's not it's really like I remember back to the really down side to it.
And something that should be used more commonly.
Next question.
Shaga mushroom question, how much powder should I use per smoothie a teaspoon a tablespoon.
I would use a teaspoon.
If you're doing one smoothie a day, you could you could use a little bit more.
I think it in a lot of polysaccharides and benefits from a teaspoon because I know you're talking about a young adult question is so for an adult you could do more than a teaspoon but if you're doing other mushrooms other polysaccharides.
And you know you don't need to overdose on it because all you'll do is just.
Just pee it out so you don't you don't want to necessarily overdose of it so with.
The person who asked this question I do a teaspoon.
Fed men can it be used for brain cancer.
I, you know, I don't know.
I do know some people who have used it for brain cancer and have had success but they're doing other things too so I don't know if it was the Fed better.
I don't know the data on whether the bed is all crosses the blood right barrier.
The truth is is that most people with brain cancer have been out enough drugs that have already damaged the blood right barrier so most likely if you have been circulating blood and across the blood right there.
So there's already damage to the blood right barrier so it would probably cross.
So there's some medications some larger chemicals and stuff that you have a barrier made up by a certain group of cells called astro sites that surround your blood vessels that go through the brain and they protect your brain from.
So I'm receiving any of those large chemicals that's called your blood right barrier it's not developed tell you're about three years old.
That's the danger of giving vaccines to children vaccines have different things in them that helped the vaccine work.
Those are very toxic chemicals to mention the mercury in the liquid in the air.
But those things readily cross the blood right barrier in a baby less than three years old because they don't have a blood right barrier so that could cause all sorts of information that damage to the brain.
There are logical centers that are just developing it is just horrible discussing it.
That's my opinion.
As we age you're taking flu shots and things like that these are micro doses nano doses of aluminum which then they say is safer for you the truth is they're actually more dangerous.
That's why it's a specialized particle of aluminum is much more dangerous than you suck it out some aluminum for.
Because that then easily readily crosses the blood right barrier and causes all sorts of damage so it's even worse.
I may be having doxal chemo for six days then a day of bladder protected bladder protected then a day of the last total eight days I assume I would wait 48 hours after all of this correct so by opinion will be after all of that then you wait 40 so you're going to be off total of eight days you're going to be off antioxidants for 10 days.
So you wouldn't be taking it out for a pack acid you wouldn't be taking curcumin during that time you would be taking vitamin C it just contact up your liaison for a list of antioxidants so you could just Google a list of antioxidants and really you want to just stay away from those strong antioxidants.
A lot of nutrients have had the accident benefits to them that you don't need to so much worry about it's just taking high doses of alcohol and pancass that are ready to see that you stay away from other questions.
Hey Dr. Connors yes what's the benefit of the hyperbaric chamber on after chemo.
So the hyperbaric chamber is pressurized oxygen so it helps pressurize oxygen in your tissues it's different than also because it's both true that you're pressurizing it's not both three so you heard by spiel earlier on.
So so it's not oxidizing it's oxygen 80 very different so yes oxygen is in 024 is very good for your brain it's very good for your other tissues but I really think the key piece of hyperbaric is for brain health.
Okay so your brain needs fuel and the fuel your brain uses is glucose and oxygen period as I else glucose and oxygen so you need both of those for brain function so using it post chemo is really to help with the damage that chemo did to your brain.
So if a person is using chemo for breast cancer still that circulating in your bloodstream pretty good chance you have some damage to your blood brain barrier some is going to cross the blood brain barrier the longer you do chemo will damage the blood brain barrier itself.
So you'll get something that crosses this is where you get the brain fog the chemo brain people have worse chemo brain than others because they had a worse damage blood brain barrier and and then that it itself will cause problems in your brain because it's going to damage microglial cells damage neurons etc.
So increase oxygenation helps the brain heal so hyperbaric chambers are great the negative about hyperbaric chambers is you have to do it fairly regularly so all the studies on hyperbaric chambers are doing it daily so it would be best if everybody had their own hyperbaric chamber.
Other negatives are people with side issues like mine can't go in them people that have claustrophobia issues can't go in them so it has some negatives but it's a great tool.
Okay, have you had any experience with anyone taking that can't run or protocell.
I'm sorry say that again.
Antron or protocells.
Yeah we use protocell so that's something we test everybody for.
Oh okay.
We have a number of people probably on this call that are taking protocell.
So protocell is a great tool.
So protocell is different than all other therapies because protocell is an oxidizing agent.
And you don't want to take a lot of antioxidants with protocell you have to take them in between the protocell dose because protocell when you're using protocell 50 or protocell 23.
It's about 4 and a half or 5 hour dose every 4 to have 5 hours you've got to take a dose you have to take it all your other supplements in between that.
It's a little bit of a hassle that way.
I've been tested and that means I didn't get it on my sheet and it's probably not going to be good for me.
Correct.
And I don't remember how long ago you were tested but you could always ask to be retested specifically tested for that but we test everybody for that so.
Okay, good to know.
Next chat question there are there may be nausea associated with chemo ideas to help will be appreciated yes there's typically nausea associated with chemo.
For many reasons or for two big reasons one of the effects your stomach can and causes an upset stomach but secondly if it's crossing the blood barrier you actually have nausea center in your membrane.
And it's part of the deep membrane so if chemo gets there that could be causing serious nausea.
So we have a product that's an herbal from herb farm is called that no nausea that has helped people with nausea from chemo or nausea from cancer have been helped with ginger.
Some people have used ginger choose you can buy those in your local grocery store.
They're just tasty little stacks they do have sugar in them but they're a lot of ginger they're very jittery a lot of pregnant women will use those.
And there's an essential oil ginger that you can use I when I had really bad nausea I used a product called digest it was from young living other such as well companies might have some similar products that helped me just putting a couple drops on my finger and putting on my tongue.
One of my patients patients have used digest or ginger that has helped.
Next question the greens first powder has antioxidants and I'm also taking a multivitamin that has 90 milligrams of vitamin C.
Those are all be acceptable during chemo so 90 milligrams vitamin C is really low and the greens versus all whole food so taking a whole food powder like that to me.
But your oncologist says that's not going to negate your your your chemo therapy so you should still be taking eyes suggest you still take those things.
There's not enough in there it's all in a whole food form like you're eating really good food are you not supposed to be food when you take that so I'm not talking to you.
This question when I'm talking about colleges that's arguing with this question so no continue to take those as we're just either other recommendations different from the standard chemo radiation detox you provide for brain cancer.
So you can reach out to your liaison for that but to detox chemo from brain cancer I think that's what you're talking about detox and chemo radiation that you're using for brain cancer no it's really no different.
The only other things that I would say is to what you're done.
The chemo that they're using for brain cancer is chemo that they're purposefully getting to use to cross the blood right there so and then any radiation to the brain is causing damage to surrounded tissue as well so there's a video on our blog if you search our blog you search brain inflammation I created a video microglial activation that I think will be helpful.
It may be scary at the same time for everybody but I think it's helpful for everybody because understanding what things cause damage to the brain that leads we're not talking just about chemo or anything like that we're talking about just the average person that is concerned about early dementia brain loss I don't want to have all centers like my mother really needs to watch that video.
Because Alzheimer's dementia and any type other type of brain demility disease is really starts with some sort of damage to the brain and how the brain actually cleans itself on the brain protects itself and how you know learning those things can support that.
So your brain gets rid of pathogens gets rid of toxins helps heal cells through specific glial cells called micro glial cells.
And I won't go too deep into it because I have a 25 minute video on it but those microglial cells could get damaged certainly when we do chemo certainly when we do radiation they get damaged more commonly in the general public from post concussion even falling baby to your head 10 years ago 20 years ago when you were a kid ice skating you fell its back your head against ice who hasn't done that in Minnesota.
So those types of post concussion damages damage microglial cells years later decades later you start to see the effects now there are specific nutraceutical things that you could do to push the dementia out and help heal the brain.
But the people to start doing it and this is well researched well documented information research has been created after the whole post concussive syndrome with football players just poured buddy into research into this and it's all coming down to really hitting the flavonoids hard.
The flavonoids are your residual your curcumin your white willow bark your anything you could think of it as an anti inflammatory agent.
The more you can help decrease the inflammation of the brain by calling down activated microglial cells the better you can feel your brain and the more you could push off dementia into the future.
So watch that video go on our website again remember that slide right here search for brain inflammation everybody watch that video.
If you have any concerns of any chemotherapy radiation affecting your brain how you can help protect it from that point on or you have any concerns of I don't want to get Alzheimer's my uncle had Alzheimer's my mother had Alzheimer's whatever it is you need to watch that video to learn how you could take care of yourself because it's actually pretty simple steps that you can do.
And you could really prevent a world of hurt and the more damage there is to your brain and the more what are called primed microglial cells that you have they don't go back so you can help a lot of things so yeah I would just look at that video and
and use some of the recommendations in there. Sorry, you already have the answers.
Is it safe to take anti inflammatory during radiation yes and yes and yes so you want to decrease inflammation during radiation so radiation is a is a beam of frequency that is going through your brain.
So the more you can protect from the inflammation you're not affecting the radiation negatively you're protecting your healthy cells from the inflammation that's caused by the damage.
Think of a beam rate that's going through there.
And then you can see that the more you can protect that the better.
My brain is swelling probably caused by the radiation therapy causing neurological symptoms my oncologist is prescribing steroids to reduce the swelling and help the symptoms is there anything you'd suggest to reduce the swelling.
Yep go back to my last answer so yes steroids are really the right thing to do because the swelling in the brain there's no place where to go.
So it will it could damage the brain because seizures and all sorts of things so going on a low dose probably on two milligrams of prednisone maybe twice a day is the right thing to do for a period of time but you don't want to stand at the rest of your life.
So the more you could jump on these things that I just mentioned these advertise those are the anti inflammatory things the better off you're going to be high dose curcumin as well yet white little bark sticky dental
Betaline from beats that betaline limitless product.
You're the respiratory the green tea extract those are the things that are going to save your brain that are going to calm that inflammation down so don't be afraid to take fairly high doses of those things remember.
This with all your supplements please all those supplements except your fat soluble supplements have a half life in your body so I'm going to take I'm going to take to a curcumin for my brain and I'm supposed to take four grams of curcumin if I take them on seven o'clock in the morning well by three o'clock in the afternoon it's pretty much all gone on your system or really the therapeutic doses you have to split them up through the day.
So they have a half life stayed in your body so your body body resorbs that gets rid of it detoxifies it like anything else and you want to keep that therapeutic dose within your system so you want to break that dose throughout the day.
CT scan done about two years after prostate to me there seems to be more action on the scan in the area where the surgery happened.
Very common that after removing your prostate in what's called the bed of the prostate where that prostate sat that there could be cancer that could take place after removal even though they have it all gone that's why you're doing the things that you're doing.
So you concern isn't that cancer is growing there yes that's always a concern some action now in the lymph nodes should my protocol change if I choose to go on antigen deprivation therapy.
I don't know your whole protocol one thing you always want to add to antigen deprivation therapy so it's taking like a loopron or something like that or a case of dex.
You want to start andrographis so andrographis is an herb we use the product viral clear that's our product that we have labeled for viruses because andrographis is so good for viruses but it is it is there's been studies show that if you're on antigen deprivation therapy which is a drug that decreases your testosterone significantly.
It will work better and it will last longer if you're coupling it with andrographis so get on viral clear you can buy that in the store and and and just start taking that like one capsule three times a day of viral clear.
Yes, I saw the direct message make sure you call the clinic and send up an appointment to chat with your liaison or myself in the show so make sure you get on viral clear right away.
Okay, any other questions alright I think we'll call it a night it's been about an hour makes everybody for eating okay so one more question back to the MRI crashed question for the MRI show something the ultrasound can't.
Now it's it's possible you know the anything's possible so if you're concerned that something is not right again you have to you have to have some faith in trusting what you're supposed to be doing so we prayed about whether you should move into the next step and do some sort of MRI or not that's the choice that you're going to have to make it's anything is possible and it could show something different so.
If you feel that concerned maybe that's the leading to do that alright thanks everybody we will see you next week and again remember to email questions and if you want an answer we'll do our best to get them and we pray for you all have a great week and I won't talk to you for Christmas so everybody have a very very Christmas.
We'll be back after Christmas Michelle will do it next week right bye bye.